depuis quelques jours les médias ton en
boucle sur une affaire l'accusation d'un
cesse de l'acteur richard berry sur sa
fille le monde du cinéma est sous le
choc
l'acteur richard berry est visé par une
plainte par sa fille et lui pour viol et
agression sexuelle doline berry qui a
porté plainte contre son père l'accusant
d'avoir abusé d'elle sexuellement
lorsqu'elle avait entre 6 et 10 ans des
actes qui auraient été perpétrées avec
la complicité de son ex belle mère la
chanteuse jeane manson petit ces
accusations se retrouve à la une des
médias c'est parce que coline berry
aujourd'hui 45 ans dans l'énergie
suscitée par le mouvement mitu inceste a
décidé de dévoiler cette affaire au
grand jour pour faire savoir à tous ceux
qu'elle reprochait à son père
seul problème avant que la justice ait
pu faire son travail richard berry qu'il
soit coupable ou non est jeté en pâture
au tribunal populaire qui a vite fait de
la condamner alors que le procès n'a pas
encore lieu font pas ça parce que c'est
moins sept ils vont savent ce que c'est
racoleur
si la présomption d'innocence est un
droit fondamental en france le fait que
les victimes fasse le choix de
médiatiser ses affaires avant que la
justice soit passé le poser question
monsieur berry a été l'agent de sa chute
puisque c'est lui qui a posté sur
instagram et ma cliente n'a fait que
répondre à ce qui était dit alors à fait
richard berry les victimes doivent-elles
rendre public leur affaire de viol
alors est-ce qu'on a d'autres infos sur
la terre je me tourne vers sur ambert
père gilles verdez qui est l'enquêteur
de l'équipe alors oui il peut dire sans
prendre du tout partie que la journée a
été un peu difficile pour richard berry
il ya deux choses d'abord la révélation
et la demie d'un terrain de violences
conjugales
donc ça n'a rien à voir avec la faire
mais ça veut dire quand même qu'un un
terrain alors il a avoué qu il a dit oui
il a reconnu des violences conjugales
voilà donc ça ça veut dire que les
enquêteurs vont vouloir en savoir plus
et justement à propos de ça l'avocate de
colline a dit que sa cliente était
favorable à une confrontation et je me
suis renseigné dans le cadre d'une
enquête préliminaire même si les faits
sont prescrits
il peut y avoir confrontation s'il ya
confrontation
chacun va donner sa vérité et cyril il
faut pas être dupe faut dire aux gens ce
qui va se passer
il y aura un procès verbal et ce procès
verbal il va fuité dans les médias c'est
sur les murs
donc ça veut dire que la richard berry
va être placé si la confrontation face à
son accusatrice et les médias à mon avis
seront immanquablement ce qui va se dire
mais judiciairement ils risquent rien
richard berry les faits sont prescrits
néanmoins les faits sont prescrits
mais quand il ya une enquête
préliminaire c'est que la justice veut
savoir si les faits n'ont pas perduré ou
si il n'y a pas d'autres victimes
il ya quand même une enquête alors oui
oui oui et quand vous dites quand on dit
qu est-ce qui risquent déjà
médiatiquement c'est vrai qu'ils
arrivent toujours ce matin j'étais
joueur sur les gens ne parlaient que de
ça sur mon affaire ce matin et notamment
les noms et prénoms si vous êtes juste
même dixième des gens qui étaient dans
le salon d esquiver cinq personnes
disaient de toute façon il n'y a pas de
fumée sans feu
c'est ça c'est un truc terrible chasse
est terrible c'est triste c'est vraiment
terrible
autre jeu vous savez bernard on a parlé
hier colline donc la victime disait que
pendant les actes a visiblement il y
avait charles est la fille de jean
wilson qui était la sirène et elle a
démenti ces faits en dessous que ce
n'est pas vrai sauf qu'il ya un sms qui
a été envoyé mi janvier et qui vient
contredire tout ça qui auraient été
envoyés par shirel elle même et qui a
dit j'ai réussi à dépasser cet épisode
et à tourner la page et à ignorer ce que
ce personnage nous a fait comme maloya
l'aurait envoyé ça j'en sais ce que
c'est à souligner du monde d'accord le
monde
il est concret sur aujourd'hui tout le
monde sur des affaires effectivement une
information à qui a passé effectivement
conjugale compliqué à qui un sms pour
quelle raison dans quel contexte on peut
pas commencer le procès de ce garçon est
d'accord je roule à dire dans les deux
cas ça va être dramatique que ce soit
vrai ou faux pouf mais là je trouve que
chacun y va de sa petite info toi tu
sors effectivement le l'info de du monde
mais encore une fois le sms dans quel
contexte il était écrit il sur quel
sujet on le sait pas assez mais sans
mordant parce que désormais on enfoncera
encore et et un couvre ou à l'enfoncer
lui les pandas mais un coup et agro
balle en fond c est donc on va où chacun
l'association d'opinion effectuée au tu
as raison au bout du bout les gens les
publics les qui nous regardent qu'est ce
qu'ils vont dire il n'y a pas de fumée
sans feu et ce à quoi qu'il arrive c'est
dramatique
voilà c'est sûr ça ne me servait pour
lui pas pour lui mais là c'est à son
comme on l'a dit la prochaine fois s'il
est innocent c'est dévastateur et à
strophes sa famille aussi et pour lui et
puis derrière reculant il tournera plus
leur image sur et a soif pour lui c'est
soit vrai ou faux la 5e place et ça même
si sûr même si les de santé dont nombre
est de toute façon les gens diront qui a
pas de fumée sans feu c'est la première
chose à la deuxième chose c'est qu'ils
commencent à reconnaître les faits de
violences et ces deux faits mais lance
donc ça y est les gens commencent à se
dire il ya un tas vue reconnaît déjà les
deux violons parce que en fait il ya un
problème entre le lien affectif que les
gens peuvent avoir avec un acteur mais
qui est richard berry on peut aimer
l'acteur richard berry sur et imaginer
tout d'un coup que richard berry
pourrait se comporter comme n'importe
qui avait pourtant c'est bien vrai vous
avez une personne qui aliment sur dix
qui peut avoir des défiances pourquoi ça
ne serait pas un acteur différent de ce
qu'il a c'est vrai mais c'est parce
qu'on sait pas ce que je veux dire c'est
qu'il vous parce qu'ils analysent et on
peut pas banaliser sa jolie nicolas
pernikoff non je ne suis pas en train de
gagner
je vous dis que c'est pas parce qu'il
est richard berry un formidable acteur
que il est il ne pourrait pas faire de
l'équilibré pas avoir de déviance donc
je vais dire ce qu'il faut cesser
décorrélée les deux c'est à dire il est
un justiciable comme un autre et un
moment donné il faut ce qu'il faut
sortir un peu de ce côté richard berry
c'est pas possible tu avais pas même ses
chalets en bois
je regarde 2000 à prendre oui moi je
pense qu'on n'est pas là pour faire
justice
on est dans un état de droit et
justement on peut aujourd'hui plaidé
pour pour une cause on peut aussi se
faire défendre qu'on a fait des bêtises
et je pense qu'aujourd'hui l'erreur
aller là comme elle disait tout à
l'heure
tiffany
on n'est pas là pour pour donner son
avis finalement est l'intérêt d'une
affaire rendue publique
ça va faire ressortir d'autres affaires
d'autres personnes en fait qui ne le
sont pas la sphère mitsou par exemple
est plein d'affaires comme ça de
personnalités plus ou moins connus au
mois précédent à faire que brésil
derrière alors à défaut oui mais c'est
pas de faire justice à juste raison sauf
que quand tu as inconnu ton affaire
allait pas rendues et la place lui qui
était pas jeter en pâture à tout le
monde
encore une fois on ne sait pas ce qui
est vrai et ce qui est faux mais dans
son cas à lui excuse moi le procès déjà
commencé et non seulement il a commencé
mais il est comme on l'avait déjà
condamné
c'est un peu un problème dont je
t'entends mais il sauf que aujourd'hui
on en parle et quand je regarde la
manière dont ces traités des deux côtés
il ya de plus en plus une accusation qui
se met en place derrière richard berry
et qui alors si c'est vrai je connais
ses rôles avec une colline par non à la
droite aujourd'hui de s'exprimer et de
parler de parler de cette histoire
d'accord il des gens qui disaient
pourquoi elle réagit autant de temps
après mais pourquoi leur âge et autant
de temps après peut-être qu'elle a fait
une psychanalyse qui l'a conduit
aujourd'hui à se poser des questions à
se remettre en question et avoir besoin
de n'évacuer ça donc il faut pas non
plus non mais il faut pas non plus être
que d'un côté et objat en moyenne vraie
question que je me pose sur ce type
d'affaires c'est celle de la nécessité
de tout déballer dans les médias c'est
aujourd'hui dans une affaire vous avez
200 khz sanctions possibles quand vous
êtes présumé coupable
la sanction judiciaire qui est d'avoir
une amende allant prison et la sanction
médiatique tout âge et immédiate
quoi qu'il arrive vous êtes cooper et
tout le monde en parle et ça ça reste à
vie et ça je trouve ça assez dégueulasse
mais j'ai aujourd'hui les familles se
déchirent dans les médias que vous le
vouliez ou non et quel que soit le sujet
sur un autre sujet la famille hallyday
s'est déchiré dans les médias alors il
ya eu aussi le tweet de saint leu leu la
réaction de carla bruni oui après voilà
le post un stade de 2 des jo diane
balasko qui disait soutien collins ou
tes acolytes soutien collins a beaucoup
divisé puisque carla bruni et tu sûr qu
qu'il est coupable
bien sûr ça ça fait beaucoup réagir
là-dessus aujourd'hui énormément et
pourquoi carla bruni réagi parce que ces
clans contre klan de manière très
violente c'est la guerre médiatique et
la guerre médiatique elle se gagne à
coups de soutien donc chaque camp compte
ses soutiens et c'est sûr que carla
bruni quelqu'un lui a demandé est de
nous on est en difficulté c'est certain
cet hymne pour répondre à ta question
mieux selon moi l'intérêt justement
c'est complètement thérapeutique le fait
d'avoir le soutien de plans de personnes
alors certes
ben moi aussi j'étais dans cette optique
là de la médiatisation d'une affaire
c'est une mauvaise idée mais l'autre
côté ça peut vachement aider et
j'aimerais rappeler qu'à l'époque de mes
parents et grands parents
le fait d'être jaurès était une honte
surtout quand la personne et est
influente quand la personne était
policière donc ça permet aussi de rendre
justice ça permet de mais en fait de
faire plein de choses ça permet d'avoir
les dents que ça peut potentiellement
brisé la vie d'un homme qui
potentiellement peut être innocent une
flat le mal est fait donc c'est pas
trouvé qui ont abrité après celle
adressée le 2 et le traitement
médiatique c'est ça mais il a dit qu' il
est coupable
non même d'être jugé est ce que quoi
qu'il arrive il est ici à bernard
montiel willaey le tribunal populaire
est terrible il donne des sanctions
avant de savoir le fond des choses et il
faut être très prudent là dessus mais
quand on parle des faits des violentes
c'est lui même qui en avait parlé c'est
en 2014 il me semble de mémoire il avait
reconnu qu'il avait eu un comportement
bon assez violent avec ses deux
compagnes ça il avait dit à l'époque et
maintenant ressort tout ça maintenant
pour créditer la thèse que c'est un
homme violent que c'est pas un type bien
et c'est donc faire très attention de la
version ancienne qu'on ressort
différence aussi entre la médiatisation
et les réseaux sociaux
et aujourd'hui c'était dangereux à notre
époque ce sont les réseaux sociaux du
coup tout le monde s'en mêle quand on
fait un article dans un journal c'est
une chose parce qu'on est effectivement
on donne des frissons souris via les
réseaux sociaux
justement tout le monde s'acharne soit
sur richard berry soit sur collines et
ça peut avoir des conséquences qui
peuvent être dramatiques pour l'un ou
pour l'autre lui même à communiquer sur
les raisons soient obligés
non mais je veux dire les réseaux
sociaux participent non seulement d'une
forme de vendetta populaire c'est sûr
mais aussi de l'expression des
protagonistes d'une affaire judiciaire
c'est sa carrière il rappeler que ce
n'est pas elle qui a commencé c'est
richard berry le premier elle elle n'a
pas comme ils l'ont déjà fait les joies
du point alors un côté d'histoire aux
téléspectateurs ça faisait ça faisait
quelques semaines qu'ils avaient
effectivement eu des informations ils
ont pu longuement hésité à publier ce
qui est fine entre est effectivement
suite à l'accumulation de différents
information qui pour l'instant à mettre
comme on dit au conditionnel
ils ont décidé de porter l affaire dans
l'eure dans leur journal mais encore une
fois un article pour le coup le sud du
point n'est pas à charge
l'article est facturé jeunes et vieux du
monde est beaucoup plus alors on va voir
ce qu'on pense les téléspectateurs s'il
vous plaît voilà oui à 42% non à 58 pour
cent ans